in heat this High a package like this
well it's worth its weight in gold
air conditioning rolled out in offices
and apartments alike the heat wave a
major boost if you're in the right sort
of business
we've seen an increase of 50 in orders
whereas a call increase of we've got a
couple hundred calls a week what the
continuous period of heat does is it
pushes people over the edge essentially
to say look this Heat's here to stay and
we can do something about it you might
well have expected a similar story here
river-based businesses surely booming
but look a normally heaving spot on the
Thames practically deserted
and why well because boat rental firms
like Sophie's have opted to close
sending people out in this heat just too
dangerous it's a real shame because yes
it's beautifully hot it's lovely
conditions out there on the River today
just a gentle breeze but we can't really
chance it you know because it is just
too hot
businesses like this clearly have a very
small footprint in terms of the overall
economy but if you extrapolate out these
decisions across the country you have a
big problem for your services being
provided for you are things being made
less money being spent and a hit to that
all-important economic measure
productivity it's what keeps the economy
healthy and growing but heat slashes
production from business sites to
offices from factories to Farms so this
is where I'll work from tomorrow
um at the desk as close to the aircon as
possible but one recent change might
help the working from home phenomena or
in Kate's case working from a hotel her
home simply too hot for a toddler and a
full day's work yes we've had to pay a
little bit of money for the hotel but
it's a good deal I don't think many
people would normally check in here on a
weekday so yeah we're happy to do it
just knowing that our dogs is going to
sleep properly and safely today we were
planning to install new windows here but
we couldn't do it because of the Heat
and then there's workers safety unions
say there should be legal limits to how
hot a workplace can be
many whose staff would be exposed as
self-regulating usually we have six to
eight people on site here working at the
same time today we only have two people
working upstairs it will be a while
before the full impact is measured but
there's no doubt many May struggle in
workplaces uncomfortably warm
Helena Smith Sky News West London